dans cette rue passante cette
chocolaterie accueille encore quelques
clients mais elle connu une chute de
moitié de ses recettes
depuis leur confinement c'est des petits
paniers en fait par rapport à d'habitude
où les gens vont passer mon faire aussi
des cadeaux pour des amis de la famille
et c'est vrai que par rapport à ça c'est
ce qui a vraiment changé
l'activité de cette boutique est réduite
pourtant à quelques kilomètres de là
l'atelier lui fonctionne à plein régime
moulage préparation des ganaches goût
framboises des coupes de chocolat en
carrés ou encore décoration des bonbons
tout doit être parfait pour la période
de noël
elle représente 50% du chiffre
d'affaires de la chocolaterie pour être
prêt à temps malgré la situation
les 17 employés sont réquisitionnés
aujourd'hui économiquement c'est pas
très intéressant de rester ouverts parce
ça m'oblige à avoir minimum de personnel
de vente par boutique
sauf que on veut pas se faire oublier
des gens et donc on doit rester dans la
dynamique de l'ouverture
et puis nous en parallèle on continue à
produire parce que il ya les calendriers
de l'avent qui vont arriver et
confinement ou pas confinement les gens
voudront leur calendrier de l'avent à
pâques pendant le dernier confinement la
chaîne avait connu une explosion des
ventes
elle espère la même dynamique pour les
fêtes de fin d'année